Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Do you remember style transfer?
Style transfer is a mostly AI-based technique
where we take a photograph, put a painting
next to it, and it applies the style of the
painting to our photo.
That was amazing.
Also, do you remember pose estimation?
This is a problem where we have a photograph
or a video of someone, and the output is a
skeleton that shows the current posture of
this person.
So how about something that combines the power
of pose estimation with the expressiveness
of style transfer?
For instance, this way, we could take a video
of a professional dancer, then record a video
of our own, let's say, moderately beautiful
moves, and then, transfer the dancer's performance
onto our own body in the video.
Let's call it motion transfer.
Have a look at these results.
How cool is that?!
As you see, these output videos are quite
smooth, and this is not by accident.
It doesn't just come out like that.
With this technique, temporal coherence is
taken into consideration.
This means that the algorithm knows what it
has done a moment ago and will not do something
wildly different, making these dance motions
smooth and believable.
This method uses a generative adversarial
network, where we have a neural network for
pose estimation, or in other words, generating
the skeleton from an image, and a generator
network to create new footage when given a
test subject and a new skeleton posture.
These two neural networks battle each other
and teach each other to distinguish and create
more and more authentic footage over time.
Some artifacts are still there, but note that
this is among the first papers on this problem
and it is already doing incredibly well.
This is fresh and experimental.
Just the way I like it.
Two followup papers down the line and we'll
be worried that we can barely tell the difference
from authentic footage.
Make sure to have a look at the paper, where
you will see how the pix2pix algorithm was
also used for image generation and there is
a nice evaluation section as well.
And now, let the age of AI-based dance videos
begin.
If you enjoyed this episode, please consider
supporting us on Patreon where you can pick
up really cool perks, like early access to
these videos, voting on the order of future
episodes, and more.
We are available at patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers,
or just click the link in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!